china's fintech giant ant group was on
pace to break ipo records
and on track to raise more than 34
billion dollars
ahead of the blockbuster listings in
hong kong and shanghai
the company's charismatic co-founder
jack ma spoke at a public forum about
how
china's financial system should be best
regulated
in a dramatic turnaround chinese
regulators brought the ipo plans to a
halt
casting doubt over the future of am so
how did plans for what would have been
the world's biggest ipo
come screeching to a hall
and has revolutionized digital finance
in china
there is nothing quite like it in
western financial circles
for china's leadership it is a source of
great pride that you have these big
powerful tech companies like anne it
handles more than 17 trillion dollars a
year in payments
it really is one of the backbones of the
e-commerce industry
many people save and invest through anne
and they also use it to borrow money as
well
it has kind of stepped in and assumed
this important position
between banks and their end customers
where it has this nice
business of kind of organizing loans
whereas the banks bear most of the
credit risk
ant has come under increasing regulatory
scrutiny partly because of its
sheer size some of the biggest potential
problems for ant
center on its loan business draft rules
covering lending done by businesses
other than banks
effectively require the company to put
more of its own skin in the game
now it needs perhaps to put as much as
30 of the
capital up itself recently ant's
co-founder jack ma
has made rather provocative speech where
he talked about how he thought the
financial system in
china should be overseen
and that perhaps was rather unwelcome
in the highest circles of the chinese
leadership
but we don't know precisely why
regulators decided to suspend the ipo
but we know that there was a meeting
between
top and executives jack ma and four of
china's major financial regulators
and a day later the stock exchange said
that actually this
couldn't go ahead for now it seems to
some observers that this is partly also
a way of
letting ant's top leaders and
controlling shareholder jack ma know
that they shouldn't
get too big for their britches in a way
that they shouldn't presume to know
what's best for
china's financial system or what kind of
regulation works best in the country
where the government likes to keep a
very tight
control on things in almost every
industry
the reaction in the markets basically
was one of shocks
shares in alibaba which owns part of ant
fell shares in the hong kong stock
exchange fell because
it was due to see a boost in trading
volumes after ant
went public and apologized to investors
for any trouble caused
and said it would embrace regulations it
has outlined how it will refund
individual investors in hong kong
investors in mainland china are still
waiting for details on how they will get
their money back
and has to kind of go back and think
about what it needs to redo
in order to kind of win the approval of
these all-powerful chinese regulators to
go public